arriving in Seoul after days of delays a
specially chartered plane returning 368
people who'd been living in Wuhan around
half the number of South Korean
nationals trapped there and wanting to
leave some were found to have fevers and
taken to hospital the rest were heading
here to one of two makeshift quarantine
centers south of the capital their
presence has led to protests from people
living nearby and police had to remove
roadblocks the government sent a
minister to reassure protesters that he
was met by angry shouts and eggs being
thrown under occupation and of course
local residents will be worried by the
prospect of patients coming to their
area but the corona virus is transmitted
in two ways by contact or by respiratory
droplets so you need to be within 1 to 2
meters of the patient to be in danger as
the convoy bringing the evacuees
approached other people turned out to
welcome them it's only natural for the
country to bring back our citizens and
treat them
what's more the people coming here have
passed the screening and don't have
symptoms after an exhausting night of
travel and health screenings their
journey is finally at an end
but now starts the quarantine in a place
they'll have to call home for the next
two weeks each person will have their
own room and are allowed to keep their
phones and computers but there'll be no
visitors while their conditions are
monitored to make sure they are free
from the corona virus at least as one of
the evacuees told us through their
social media account they're back on
South Korean soil and what they call the
nightmare of Wuhan is behind them
Rob McBride al Jazeera ass and South
Korea